bonsoir nous sommes le 5 décembre il est
18h si vous nous suivez en direct et
comme chaque soir nous faisons le tour
de l'actualité locale le journal de la
rédaction voici les titres de ce 78
lactu nouvelle mobilisation contre les
maladies rares dès ce vendredi le
Téléton depuis 1987 des heures de
program sur les chaînes du service
public mais aussi des actions de
bénévoolle à travers toute la France
nous verrons comment cela va se passer
dans les ivelines dans un instant avec
nos invités le 31 décembre il sera trop
tard si vous avez déménagé récemment il
faut vous inscrire à nouveau sur les
listes électorales de votre ville afin
de pouvoir participer aux municipal mais
aussi aux européennes près de 170 élèves
du département participent en ce moment
au prix littéraire de la région
Île-de-France ils lisent les ouvrages
d'auteur sélectionnés et en rencontre
certains l'image du jour pour débuter ce
sont ces écoles fermées symbole d'une
nouvelle mobilisation des enseignants
contre les rythmes scolaires comme ici
devant l'établissement André Gide à
maniléamoau ce midi la mobilisation en
France touchait un peu moins de 19 % des
enseignants contre 23 % au mois de
novembre pour les Yvelines on évoque
officiellement en fin de journée 9,71 %
de grevistes du côté de l'inspection
académique le snip FSU principal
syndicat mobilisé rappelle ne pas être
contre la réforme mais demande nouveau
tour de table et une reprise des
discussions le Téléton 2013 coup
d'envoie demain vendredi 30h de fête et
de solidarité à travers la France comme
l'annoncent les organisateurs ce sera
aussi dans les Yvelines grâce aux
nombreux bénévoles mais aussi grâce à
deux piliers que l'on retrouve mobilisés
depuis des années et que l'on retrouve
depuis des années sur ce plateau bonsoir
Daniel Bazan coordinateur du Téléton
linest et bonsoir à Daniel Tamam
président d'objectif Téléton pour Manil
et un mot combien d'années de
mobilisation à vous deux autour du
Téléton depuis quand pour vous 27 et
pour vous oh à peu près dans les mêmes
eau qui fait de nombreuses années je pas
assez fort en calcul mental pour
calculer tout ça le Téléton qui va
débuter dès demain à travers la France
vous allez organiser les animations enin
forcément de récolter des fonds peut
peut-être juste déjà évoquer le bilan de
l'an dernier comment ça s'était passé
sur Manil et am tout d'abord man une des
communes qui marche bien très bonne
mobilisation un bon chiffre à peu près
constant par rapport aux années
précédentes vous étiez autour deux si
vous avez encore à peu près le chiffre
en tête
3300 60 à peu près c'est assez précis ce
qui concernait Eveline est le secteur
Eveline est c'était très bien l'année
dernière on a fait
426000 066 exactement pour 103 contrats
donc on a une hausse on avait une hausse
déjà l'année dernière malré la baisse au
national il y avait une baisse à peu
près 5 % au national sur le 36 37 sur le
fameux numéro qu'il son composé sur le
36 37 mais au niveau de la forceet
les ouais on était en hausse déjà
l'année dernière et cette année ça
remonte encore alors combien d'actions
sont prévues sur votre secteur Eveline S
qui couvre quel bassin combien de
communes vous vous supervisez je couvre
102 communes et j'ai 109 contrats à
l'heure actuelle donc j'espère encore en
avoir demain quels sont les rendez-vous
pas principaux ils sont tous sont
importants pour récolter tous les
bénévoles sont mobilisés mais quels sont
ceux les animation à mettre en avant
dont on peut parler ce soir ben je vais
dire notre village d'accueil de saintr
reuse donc qui se présente bien un
village d'accueil qui regroupe
l'ensemble des communes de enfin une
partie de l'ensemble des communes de la
Vallée de Chevreuse Saint-Rémi dans
Chevreuse saint-forger tout ça donc très
bonne mobilisation sur le terrain un fil
rouge avec le tennis donc qui va
commencer donc à partir de 18h demain
soir et terminer 23h donc donc samedi
soir village d'accueil on peut
repréciser ce qu'est un village
d'accueil sur une opération ça change
chaque année de lieu le village
d'accueil et ben c'est une
représentation de notre coordination sur
le département donc on demande un peu
plus que l'ordinaire donc à ce village
il représente l'ensemble de la
coordination des ivelines et pour le
programme complet rendez-vous sur le
site internet de la coordination vous
aurez toutes les animations qui sont
prévues sur ce secteur un focus sur
manilamo tout de même vous avez toujours
un Parin une marine de prestige cette
année encore ou al on a une marine
effectivement une jeune chanteuse qui
est à
Malta connu localement détectter à 4 ans
un bel espoir et pour nous c'est un
c'est c'est un symbole a 17 non elle en
a 17 absolument ou c'est ca oui et le
parrain Jean-Luc et Tori donc on entend
un peu parler de lui en ce moment
footballeur 602 sélection euh voilà un
beau prestige aussi ça c'est pour
l'aspect on va dire prestige voilà c'est
c'est l'image c'est l'image maintenant
ce ce Téléton il va se faire avec une
vingtaine d'association il démarre
demain à 19h un fil rouge le tennis
également et des animations qui vont se
succéder on va changer en gros toutes
les demi-heur ceci pendant 26 27 he on
verra quand les gens seront fatigués
nous nous sommes nous sommes nous sommes
en forme vous êtes mobilisé depuis la
fin des années 80 ce que vous disez au
début en introduction vous avez toujours
la même énergie c'est toujours aussi
ouou est a des années où comment ça s
passé cette année déjà est-ce que ça a
été déjà pour trouver les bénévoles
est-ce que ça été compqué on a aucun
problème pour trououver des bénévoles à
Manil àau nous sommes à peu près une
centaine sur le terrain et ça c'est
extraordinaire des gens nous appellent
encore cet après-midi est-ce que comment
peut-on aider ça c'est
fabuleux c'est c'est toujours un petit
peu difficile parce qu'il y a une
coordination d'une vingtaine
d'associations de 100 bénévoles et une
logistique lourde mais quel plaisir PL
marche toujours dans le même sens je
dirais moi qui a une grosse mobilisation
au niveau des étudiants hein c'est la
première année où on recueille autant de
d'étudiants pour donc organiser quelque
chose pour le téléts sur guilloncour sur
Montini sur véisie versaill on a des
activités presque dans tous les
bâtiments c'est plôt mess c'est la
première fois que depuis que je suis à
la
coordination que cette chose se produit
hein ambiante et bien voilà un message
qui va dans le sens contraire et c'est
plutôt rassurant il y a réellement la
relève qui se fait au niveau des
étudiants donc c'est très bien on va
juste faire une petite pause nous allons
voir si vous avez prévu quelque chose
pour le Téléton allez-vous y participer
micro trottoir on vous
écoute le programme pour le Téléton on
en a pas particulièrement mais nous on
va regarder à la télévision puis avec
les enfants leur expliquer un peu
comment quel est le principe du Téléton
pour qu'ils aident un peu tout le monde
en grandissant aussi bah les danses des
enfants les danses à nous et puis ça
fait déjà tout le weekend il y a
vendredi soir ma fille samedi après-midi
nous plus hlas d'autres chos le samedi
matin au niveau scolaire oh bah j'en ai
pas encore programme pour le Téléton
vous allez fa peut-être que j'irai à la
salle là-bas des fois il y a des
enveloppes à prendre on prend des
enveloppes on boit quelque chose sur
place et puis voilà quoi je regarde un
peu ce que ce qui se passe mais non
c'est vrai que j'y fais pas très
attention on va dire et ben écoutez je
je suis bénévole au Secours populaire
donc je vais tenir le stand samedi toute
la journée de 9h à 11h enfin 23h les
bénévoles qui vont pas manquer de
travail et il y aura tout même des gens
pour venir vous rendre visite même s'il
y en a encore qui n'ont pas fait leur
programme pour le Téléton on imagine
qu'ils seront nombreux vous en vous
savez combien de personnes vous
accueillez en général sur ce genre
d'événement des milliers c'est pas
facile de compter parce que ça s'il y a
un nonstop pendant 26 27 he c'est assez
compliqué mais ça marche toujours très
très bien ces moments importants à cette
collectte de don au moment des de cette
fête qui est organisée c'est une grande
fête le Téléton mobilisation annuelle
euh les malades qui sont présents
également et c'est l'occasion d'échanger
avec eux c'est comment c'est perçu du
côté des malades cette fois-ci très bien
très bien perçu cette année au niveau
national on a cinq familles qui ont
participé donc sur l'affiche et on a la
chance c'est d'avoir un enfin la chance
c'est un grand mot d'avoir un petit donc
le petit Tibo de Triel donc qui était
parmi nous le 19
octobre et pour le lancement officiel
donc du Téléton à Buc et là j'ai eu
l'occasion de le rencontrer encore la
semaine dernière il était avec moi donc
à l'université de vous interr le voici
Tibao on le voit à l'image on l'avait
rencontré pour tvfilm il y a pas très
longtemps donc c'est je dirais que c'est
c'est très bien et c'est peut-être ce
qui motive un peu plus les jeunes aussi
euh dans l'université donc comme son
papa est donc à l'université de véisi à
l'ité de vizi donc ça peut peut-être
mobiliser aussi Mobilis on l'espère on
l'espère même chose sur Manil les bades
aussi sont présents on les rencontre au
détour des animations et on échange avec
eux ils sont ils viennent aussi pour
expliquer leur quotidien il y a
effectivement quelques quelques
personnes en fauteuil qui qui viennent
elles sont très contentes de voir cette
mobilisation je je rejoins Daniel Bazan
beaucoup de jeune sur le terrain mais
beaucoup d'anciens aussi il il y a
toutes les tranches d'âge et tout tout
le monde est satisfait he lorsque des
malades ou les enfants malades ou leurs
parents sont là et voient toute cette
mobilisation et toute cette énergie qui
est déployé c'est c'est votre plus beau
souvenir du
Téléton ben c' était mon premier Téléton
à Montini où j'en garde un grand
souvenir et j'espère que Montini un jour
et ben sera un village d'accueil j'ai
grand espoir quand même avant de quitter
la coordination mon plus beau souvenir
nous étions le premier village Téléton
c'était magnifique voilà on a commencé à
travailler avec Daniel à ce moment-là
allez on vous le redit il est important
de donner au 36 37 cet argent récolt qui
permet ensuite d'alimenter la recherche
pour une centaine d'euros de verser 81
finance ses missions sociales et ces
thérapeutique mais aussi l'aide aux
malades l'argent collecté au profit de
lafm qui est reversé en grande partie
donc au généon ce laboratoire de
recherche qui est installé à Ry il nous
a ouvert ses portes alors que les se
poursuivent et que les premiers
médicaments pourraient être
commercialisés dès 2017 Catherine
zulato un laboratoire de recherche
financée à 90 % par des dons de
particuliers c'est unique et c'est le
généton créé en 1990 grâce au dons du
Téléton pour lutter contre les maladies
rares ce sont aujourd'hui 230 experts
qui conçoivent développent et produisent
des thérapies pour traiter les maladies
génétiques rares ces thérapie intéresse
peu l'industrie pharmaceutique et
pourtant cela sert à tous les malad RAR
c'est 3 million de personnes en France
alors c'est évidemment chacune de ces
maladies touche un nombre limité de
personnes mais au global c'est 3
millions de personnes touché en France
par les maladie rare 30 millions de
personnes touchées par une maladie rare
en Europe donc un véritable problème de
santé publique et en même temps les
innovations thérapeutiques qui sont les
innovations thérapeutiques de poes qu'on
fait ici dans le domaine de la thérapie
génique par exemple C innovations
thérapeutiques de pointe serviront
également pour les maladies fréquentes
quand on travaille sur une malades rare
du système nerveux et bien évidemment ce
qu'on pourra servir pour des maladies
plus fréquentes du système nerveux
maladie neurodégénératif maladie de
Parkinson maladie d'Alzheimer dans cette
banque d'ADN par exemple on collecte les
prélèvements de familles atteintes de
maladie génétiqu on en extrait la
matière première pour la mettre à la
disposition de la recherche et grâce au
don du Téléton tout est allé assez vite
téton a vraiment permis de développer
des outils thérapeutiques que l'on a
testé dans un premier temps chez des
souris pour le petit animal et
maintenant j'ai généton on est vraiment
au stade des essais chez l'homme et ça
c'est vraiment la grande grande première
aujourd'hui le fait d'être au stade des
essais chez l'homme de produire dans des
plus grandes quantités ces médicaments
expérimentaux c'est vraiment le but que
nous nous étions fixés même si le but
ultime ce sera vraiment la mise sur le
marché le plus largement pour pour les
patients mais c'est vraiment pour nous
un changement de dimension un changement
d'échelle et le résultat de de de 25
années d'espoir de vecteur la mise à
disposition des médicaments pour les
patients ce sera pour 2017 pour se faire
généon évolue de laboratoire de
recherche associatif à but non lucratif
il vient d'obtenir le statut
d'établissement pharmaceutique ce qui va
permettre au laboratoire de produire
lui-même demain les médicaments espérés
c'estd si le programme a toujours besoin
de plus de financement et attend donc
beaucoup de cette nouvelle édition du
Téléton la recherche les avancées de la
médecine de la science on vous en parle
sur le terrain c'est des questions qu'on
vous pose lors des des différents
rendez-vous organisés pas spécialement
hein parce que bon ça c'est surtout la
partie je vais dire d'vr donc les gens
aiment bien savoir pourquoi donne est-ce
que ça sert est-ce que c'est c'est utile
on va pas revenir sur les polémiques où
où il y a eu aussi cette cette question
de savoir si le Téléton ne vampirisait
pas tous les dons par exemple c'est pas
la question de de ce soir mais les gens
veulent savoir tout de même oui oui oui
oui les gens savent enfin ils savent ils
veulent savoir et on a de plus en plus
de demandes pour visiter donc généon
donc c'est une très belle chose et puis
là et ben ils sont au contact avec les
chercheurs donc que ils peuvent déjà
avoir un petit peu un aperçu de d'où va
leur argent tout ça et je crois que ça
marche très bien c'est une structure qui
ouvre assez facilement ces portes
d'ailleurs le généon je tiens à le
souligner parce qu'on y accueillli assez
facilement pour voir ce qui s'y fait
voilà et après le bouche à oreille
marche très bien donc non non sur le
terrain on vous en parle pour ououi
absolument on peut pas imaginer que
quelqu'un fasse un don sans savoir
quelle est sa desstination donc nous
avons des éléments de réponse factuel
factuel c'est indispensable vous êtes
formé en tout cas informé pour pouvoir
transmettre cette information vous en
savez suffisamment pour pouvoir en
parler merci donc à tous les deux d'être
venus on va redonner les horaires des
différents événements le Téléton Amani
gymnase Chantal modui ce sera à partir
de 19h dès ce vendredi le village
d'accueil cette année pour les Yveline
est se trouve à l'espace jeanracina
saintréi les chevreuses et puis le
programme complet ville par ville sur le
site de la coordination Eveline est et
ce fameux 36 37 à composé merci encore à
vous merci on reste dans le domaine de
la santé et de la solidarité les élus du
conseil municipal des jeunes de Montini
le bretonux se sont retrouvés hier
devant les locaux du Pôle Jeunesse de la
ville ils ont mené une opération de
sensibilisation autour du vage pour
attirer l'attention du plus grand nombre
un jongleur était aussi présent les
passants pouvaient aussi faire des dons
pour àchef prévention une association
évelinoise qui intervient dans le
département pour notamment des
dépistages stage minute du sida les
représentants du CMJ qui en ont profité
pour rappeler que tout au long de
l'année il était aussi possible de
trouver au Pôle Jeunesse information de
Montini des conseils s'ils ont besoin
d'information il y a le pôle jeunesse et
pôle d'information santé qui est là pour
ça pour leur donner des informations le
don aussi des moyens et les accompagner
ou les aider si jamais ils sont
confrontés ce gen de choses finalement
c'est quelque chose qu'on croit toujours
connaître et qu'on connaît pas vraiment
donc il y a toujours besoin de
sensibilisation et pré tion et voilà les
élections municipales et européennes
approchent ceux qui ne sont pas encore
inscrits sur les listes électorales on
jusqu'au 31 décembre pour le faire et
nouveauté cette année les inscriptions
sur internet yolen
torrz il vous reste un peu plus de TR
semaines pour vous inscrire sur les
listes électorales une fois passé le 31
décembre toutes les inscriptions seront
closes pour voter aux élections
municipales les 23 et 30 mars prochain
une démarche qui concerne uniquement
ceux qui ont changé de domicile depuis
les dernières élections nouveauté cette
année on peut s'inscrire sur le web à
partir de chez soi les communes
volontaires ont un lien sur leur site
internet qui renvoie directement au site
de l'État il y a tout un tout un
formulaire qui qui s'ouvre et ça prend à
peu près une bonne dizaine de minutes
pour que la personne
s'inscrive sur les listes électorales
donc son dossier est envoyer en mairie
la mairie réceptionne les pièces
c'est-à-dire une copie de la carte
d'identité et une copie de l'attestation
de de domicile cette nouvelle procédure
évite au français de venir en mairie de
faire une démarche papier je dirais en
mairie et donc d'avoir cette cette
transcription automatique grâce à
Internet lorsque la demande est validée
l'électeur reçoit un accusé de réception
avant le courrier lui confirmant son
inscription il faudra en revanche
attendre le mois de février pour
recevoir la carte d'électeur le fameux
sésame pour aller voter bien entendu il
est toujours possible de se déplacer
directement en mairie pour faire la
démarche pour la 13e année consécutive
lycéen étudiant de toute l'Île de France
était invité à une journée pédagogique
sur les métiers du chiffre en clair les
métiers d'expert comptbl et de
commissair en compte une filière peu
connue et qui cherche à redorer son
image clerire
Cambier ce mercredi il y avait fou
devant la grande scène du chaîné dans la
salle pas de pièce de théâtre mais une
conférence sur les métiers du chiffre
expert comptable ou commissaire au
comptees des carrières méconnues du
grand public et qui souffrent d'un
déficit d'image cette journée
pédagogique visait à briser les clichés
et à faciliter l'orientation des jeunes
un organisateur nous confie avoir
découvert le métier de commissaire au
comptte à seulement 22 ans pour être
tout à fait honnête euh la première
chose c'était déjà à l'époque l'absence
de chômage quasiment dans cette voie
donc c'est la première chose ensuite
j'ai goûté au commissariot compte sur le
terrain en faisant des stages et c'est
ce qui m'a donné goût à cette profession
parce
que on voit l'ensemble beaucoup de
secteurs d'activité c'est la diversité
de de contact puisque on change de
client très régulièrement aussi la
possibilité de voyager puisque on a des
clients partout en France et même à
l'international donc c'est tous ces
aspects là qui qui m'ont plu dans dans
ce métier qui m'ont encourager à
poursuivre des métiers diversifiés au
salaire attractif à partir de 28000 €
annu pour les stagiaires près de 600
étudiants de toute la région sont venus
pour découvrir cette filière cette 13e
édition a pu révéler des vocations tout
du moins aider les étudiants en
comptabilité à y voir plus clairi ça m'
appris que c'était le je savais pas
avant ça quand même pas la comptabilité
donc je rend vers le management c'est
déjà sair plus sur métiers là que je
conis pas et aussi donc rencontrer des
professionnel tout à l'heure on a parlé
avec expert comptable je aller voir
d'aut personn
pourir prochaines années la profession
devrait recruter 10000 nouveaux
commissaires au compte et autant
d'experts
comptables culture il sont lycéen
apprenti stagiaire de la formation
professionnelle près de 170 élèves du
département participe en ce moment au
prix littéraire de la région îlede
France ils lisent les ouvrages des
auteurs sélectionnés et ils en ont
rencontré ce mercredi au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline quelques-uns
une rencontre pleine d'enthousiasme
suivi par Catherine zulato et Jonathan
villman Marc Potrel est l'auteur de Pola
ce jour-là au théâtre de 50 ans nel
signe une dédicace pour Sarah élève de
seconde fascinée par le livre on
comprend comment ils ont ils ont vu la
chose pour pouvoir l'écrire et après on
a une vision différente du livre comme
moi j'ai lu Marc Potrel polaire et j'ai
vu bah que c'était ce qui lui est arrivé
en fait comme une autobiographie enfin
j'ai envie de le relire pour pouvoir me
dire ça c'est vraiment passé et pour
pouvoir tout revivre ben en vrai quoi il
y a des des des choses qui qui qui
comprennent pas ou ils disent l'héroïne
on sait pas ce ce qu'elle veut ou le
narrateur il hésite des des des choses
que me disent pas les les gens de de 30
ans qui qui ont plus de plus
d'expérience de la vie là c'est vraiment
des lecteurs jeunes ça c'est intéressant
Marc Potrel est l'un des auteurs
sélectionnés pour participer au Prix
littéraire des lycéens apprentis et
stagiaires de la formation
professionnelle les élèves ont lu les
livres et doivent en faire une sélection
un travail différent du quotidien
scolaire et cela plaît ils étaient très
contents de faire quelque chose qui
était pas forcément en rapport avec le
programme quelque chose d'un peu gratuit
quelque chose qui donne d'ailleurs pas
lieu à une note à une évaluation ou à
quoi que ce soit c'est vraiment c'est
c'est pour le plaisir je lis depuis pas
longtemps en fait je me suis mis à la
lecture seulement à 12 ans parce que
quand j'étais petite le livre c'était
mon pire ennemi mais en ce moment oui je
je lis même de gros livres et ça
m'impressionne vraiment enfin voilà
pourquoi c'était ton pire ennemi ben je
sais pas je quand je en fait c'est
surtout parce que on m' obligé à lire et
m'obliger c'est vraiment pas le meilleur
moyen de pour que je le fasse quoi
pas d'obligation donc juste du plaisir
une initiative proposée par la région en
collaboration avec des librairies des
médiathèques et des établissements
scolaires en tout 40 lycées partenaires
preuve qu'à l'heure des tablettes et
d'Internet le livre a sa raison d'être
ils envoi des textoau ils lisent les
textos ils lisent les livres ils lisent
la revue ils lisent des journaux ils
lisent les panneaux publicitaires et et
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser il
il continue à lire et et s'accroche
c'est la trème édition de ce prix
littéraire les élèves ont jusqu'au mois
de février pour désigner leur lauréat
par département le prix sera
officiellement remis à l'occasion du
Salon du livre en mars
prochain 17e concours de de plédoirie
des lycéens après avoir délibéré le jury
a décerné le premier prix à Pauline ibgi
pour alerte au soja mortifère une élève
du lycée franco-allemand de Buc qui
rejoindra le 31 janvier au Mémorial de
cand et les 13 autres finalistes des
jury régionaux pour cette dernière
manche donc du 17e concours de la
plédoirie des lycéens comme chaque anné
et à quelques semaines de Noël armée de
liste les clients afflu dans les
magasins de jouets quels vont être les
cadeaux préférés des enfants c'est
l'angoisse des parents et forcément du
Père Noël Antony resh et Patrick
jaacques de dixmud ainsi qu'éodim moine
sont allés tester toutes ces
nouveautés si les parents nont assé de
laisser leurs smartphon à leurs enfants
ils peuvent désormais être tranquilles
la génération dite y maîtrise à la
perfection les tablettes numériques et
les plus précoces vont pouvoir les
prendre en main à partir d'un an ou de
l'avantage c'est que ça concentre quand
même plein d'activités qu'on peut
retrouver sur plein de plein de supports
différents parce que il y a du coloriage
il y a des activités créatrices du du
manuel et aussi du du ludique de
l'apprentissage des leçons même parce
que vous avez vous avez plein de de
possibilités pour pour travailler le
français les mathématiques sur ce genre
de d'appareil et c'est pas connecté
internet pour ce modèle là par exemple
en particulier donc il y a pas de risque
toujours aussi moderne ces figurines
peuvent se connecter au jeux vidéo grâce
à leur socle chez les demoiselles les
poupées à la mode vampire restent très
prisé mais il va falloir choisir si on
l'écoutait il prendrait tout donc du
coup on a pris on a varié en fonction
bah là dans LEGO dans le type de les
thèmes différents pour qu'il a un peu
tout pour varier mais pas chaque boîte
qu'il a mis dans cet autre grand magasin
retour au succès des années 90 cette
célèbre peluche animé est déjà le
produit le plus vendu au mois de
novembre né il y a 15 ans ce jouet
interactif doit être traité avec grand
soin et son jeune propriétaire va même
pouvoir lui apprendre une autre langue
c'est un petit monstre qui on lui donne
à manger on s'en occupe on et on lui
apprend à parler par que début il parle
Furby et après faut lui apprendre à
parler français donc c'est l'enfant
adore pour faire face à la demande ces
magasins de jouets ont doublé leurs
effectifs pour aider le Père Noël à
apporter tous les cadeaux sous le sapin
le mois de décembre représente environ
40 % de leur chiffre d'affaires
annuel le journal qui revient demain
replay sur le site internet de la chaîne
commentaire sur les réseaux sociaux #tle
78 actu excellente
soirée